détective, il y a une situation qui
exige le meilleur des meilleurs, nous ne portons pas de
manoirs en briques et nous savons qui
n'est pas excité Je passerai toute ma
carrière à essayer de m'abattre ne
quitte jamais les manoirs en briques et il y a des
points de contrôle partout s'il n'y a pas d'informations à l'
intérieur  aucun
grand manoir de glace ne remplit l'espace de mon
père dans le futur il y a une
bombe nucléaire qui se retrouve entre les mains de certains
seigneurs de la guerre du ghetto et la ville devient
folle pour essayer de l'empêcher de partir
parler de cette bombe que vous avez dû acheter
il va vous rendre un peu anxieux en
prenant mon Aleksandr ne vous inquiétez pas de notre
parcours dans les dispositions des personnages et sur
quel jeu vous savez parfois être un
leader de votre communauté même si ce
leader est une force négative allons-y D
leadership et moi  pense que le terrain est de
Dieu qu'en raison de son environnement, il est
obligé de vivre une vie négative, mais
il y a une nuance positive à son sujet
qu'il est vous savez à la recherche d'une
voiture réelle genre de voir que l'on
connaît  Han oui je crois que le poste
de police a fermé à peu près au même moment l'
école de maître l'hôpital et toutes les
autres choses du gouvernement mais nous
n'avons pas mangé ici c'est de la merde cool
je veux dire j'ai grandi sur le sien qui a grandi sur
sa musique il est vraiment  humilié, il est
vraiment honnête, il n'y a pas de front avec elle,
alors amusez-vous avec ce casting, vous avez un
garçon Gucci jouant l'un de nos gars et Alyssa
jouant au visa, c'est beaucoup de voiture poursuivant
beaucoup d'action et tout pour essayer de le
mettre dedans et tordu  les politiciens
les quartiers dangereux aiment prendre des
stéroïdes
laissez-moi tomber
je pense que tout ce saut sur les
toits perd ses billes